in the finale can we see you and kevin
may be
thinking about something i think you're
a great person
yeah i think we've got great
what is this vibes
[Laughter]
looking at me like you want to kiss me
and [ __ ] you know i look at you like
i think it's the other way around over
here i don't know maybe
you got a crush on me i get it the last
moment we had together at that party
i felt a spark but i was like is this
because we're in the moment
like this feels wrong like she hated me
i hated her
can you give me any info of where things
go after that conversation
where things go where they are
oh boy kevin kevin you know kevin and i
have such a um
weird relationship but we get along at
the same time
um he's a very nice guy you know on the
show
i think a lot of people might think like
oh why she's so mean to it's just
he reminds me of like you know you ever
have a group of like you ever have a
friend that you can just
say whatever to and they just kind of
like put up with it well kevin is
that friend to me you know and
i love seeing him get mad sometimes
because you know
it's just exciting that's all
right arm are you giving it a shot is
this an
actual relationship you would consider
or is or is that just fun
i don't know i'm stupid some beans
fighting in my dm stuff you know um
[Laughter]
okay i don't know we're just gonna have
to see i don't know
i think kevin's interested in kim
because i spoke to him like three days
ago
insider scoop spoiler alert um you know
um
you know kevin's like i kind of like him
you know and
we'll see yeah she's a friend now it's
like i i really care about her i don't
want to
just do it because she's feeling
vulnerable and there's a spark i want to
do because it's like
something real and then kane can buy our
verses
what do you think of them maybe becoming
a couple
well
it could be fun to watch but it
could be also a mistake one one or the
other
on the other hand it could be the right
match
they both want
something for themselves just hopefully
they'll do it together
hopefully i definitely i'm gonna give
love a shot
because all my life i've always been
you know this strong independent girl
that's all about
get your career first and love is always
gonna be there but i feel like if i
put all that energy into love
it might work so i'm open to that that's
where i'm at right now so i'm actually
manifesting i'm praying every day i'm
like you know if i can manifest
i'm gonna manifest this
is love does love mean kevin
you know kevin's got great traits too
but then
i know too much about his dating life so
i don't know
okay kim's not gonna have a problem he's
gonna have guys
lying out the door for her
you